Maur a new study from the University of
California San Francisco says nearly one
in three young adults may be especially
vulnerable to the corona virus our dr.
David agus joins us from Los Angeles was
more on that part of the story
hey David egg it's very good to see you
so what is happening with the young
people is my first question and for the
purposes of this conversation what do we
mean by young people the age range from
what to what
hey good morning Gail I don't want to
offend you on this but young in this
study is kind of eighteen to twenty five
and what it showed is that a lot more
either my believe me what is showing in
this study is that a lot more of them
are at higher risk for complications
from kovat than was previously thought
you know what's been observed is over
the last several months there's a 300%
increase in this age group being
admitted to hospitals and what we know
now is that a third of them are higher
risk because dominantly they've been
smoking in the last thirty days as well
as other medical conditions but smoking
Dwarfs all of the other issues yeah
we've heard about smoking and vaping and
a couple of vaping advocacy groups have
told us in statements that the data does
not tie vaping to Kovan 19 what are your
thoughts on that well I don't think the
the were tying Kovan 19 to vaping but
certainly vaping in the last 30 days and
tobacco in the last 30 days we think
puts you at significantly higher risk
for complications from kovat 19 because
of the inflammation and the lung and it
really needs to be proven otherwise in a
definitive study before anybody will
back away from that statement and
researchers in London have found that
people who recover from koban 19 may
lose their immunity sooner than first
thought
what does that mean so this was a study
that followed hospital workers and 60
percent of them had antibody levels
three weeks that's the highest antibody
goes three weeks after infection that
will prevent the virus and we thought
can give them protection but when you
look three months later that number is
down to 20% so the antibodies have a
very short half-life it's not as
doom and gloom as it sounds because much
of the immunity to Kovan 19 is from
t-cells and we aren't measuring them in
these studies and t-cells have a memory
and provide immunity against the virus
after being exposed the vaccines are
given in two shots so we can get a much
higher concentration of antibodies then
you were just infected with the virus
so a couple with the vaccines and the
t-cell part of the response both to the
vaccines and the virus my hope is it
last significantly longer immunity to
the virus
now what everybody wants David agus you
know is a vaccine I know you you've been
working on a database to advise
volunteers about this what are you
finding how is that going is a better
question how is that going well what's
exciting is is that this is a database
where you log on the lining everybody in
the audience can log in they can
volunteer to be part of the phase 3
clinical trials for the vaccine and the
antibody and we're looking for people of
every race every part in the country
every age to have a distribution and to
enroll people it was announced by dr.
Falchi and the NIH mid last week there
are already 60 plus thousand people I
just checked this morning that have been
volunteered to be part of this heroes
who want to be part of the solution and
later this week there's going to be a
lot more media on it so those numbers
are expected to rise significantly we're
looking for a million people in total to
be volunteers in this program hey David
we had a report on the on this broadcast
earlier about the White House seeming to
try to discredit dr. pouchy who as you
know is widely respected according to
the latest polls you know both sides
here what is your take on what is
happening well he's widely respected not
just according to the polls he's just
widely respected I honestly don't know
I mean Falchi is a voice of reason in
science and he is a powerful leader for
what is happening with koban 19 and the
country trusts him in order to get
normative behavior change you need
leadership and he has provided
leadership that's on behind what he's
pushing obviously there's been a lot of
infighting in the
my house on all different areas and III
don't know what specifically happening
between them but I hope he continues to
lead yes I think many people hope that
doctor foul she always says stick with
the science I always take that to heart
thank you very much dr. David